hello everyone this is the order flows
trade analysis for monday jun 13 2016 my
name is mike koval closed i'm the
founder and trader at order flows calm
first a brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only and should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision future
trading contain substantial risk and is
not for every investor investor could
potentially lose all or more and the
initial investment risk capital is money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
trading anyway those with sufficient
risk capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results first talk
about the tools that I use in this
presentation the first one is the order
flows trader software which I developed
it's a order flows so footprint chart
volume footprint chart so you can see
who's in control of the market then
there's a couple proprietary indicators
additional indicators that are not part
of the order flow traders that I've
developed they were to flow Delta
scalper and the order flow price
rejecter today you'll see some trades
taken with the odor flows price rejecter
when it's imposed on top of the order
closed trader it runs on the NinjaTrader
trading platform which is free and you
know if you open an account with ninja
trader brokerage you get very good
commissions and a discount on the paid
version of ninja trader so that said
let's jump in okay my first trade was in
the e-mini mini 5 range chart I prefer
range charts over minute charges because
I like to see how price rotates from one
level to another rather than all of a
sudden you got to form a new bar because
it's you know 834 835 you know I I'd
rather have a bar for me when prices
moving as opposed to time and this is
the first trade i took this morning it
was uh just just before nine o'clock i
got short off this is the price rejecter
giving me a cell i have a divergence you
know negative Delta at a new or equal hi
I do you know I excited get short here
at eighty five and a half and you know
my stop was at 87 came up touched that
high again at six and a half and started
going down you know my target was around
the 83 area 82 and a half
but we couldn't we couldn't really put
in that move you know the fact that we
came back up to the high again was it
was not encouraging but then you know I
got a ratio there which is really sort
of kept me you know kept me bearish on
this trade and I said we came down to 84
and a quarter before turning back up and
stopping me out at 87 and a half so you
know the first trade i took this morning
was a loser and you know I wasn't happy
about it but not every trade you have is
going to be a winner you got to have
stops in there you know there's only a
point a half it's you know I'll say only
a point and a half but you know it's a
relatively tight stop no I was how to
stop in of a point and a half but i was
looking to get three points out of it so
it was a two-to-one trade anyway we took
out the high made a new high here at
seven and three-quarters they didn't
then we started coming off again I got
ratio ratio ratio we don't have a we
don't have a divergence here but you do
have a ratio indicating you know the
prices are being rejected up here they
get racial racial racial got short here
at four and a half you know three in a
row I was looking for a bit of a pull
back up towards here and you know it did
come in yeah I'm short at four and a
half but got down to two and a half and
you know it's one of those things you
know it was a two-point move no but I
want us looking for two-and-a-half to
three points out of it you know so it
got within you know two ticks of mine
like take profit started to turn around
i had price rejecter given a buy signal
here so you know again you know I was
short but then I've seen you know sort
of an opposing signal here so in the end
I covered it at four so i made a half a
half a point let me two ticks out of it
and you know the market did trade back
up two you know five and three-quarters
and just kind of went sideways so you
know to get you know get that you know
again it's you know I'd have preferred
to have gotten out a bit lower but you
know when you see things in the order
flow that are telling you hey you know
your initial thinking is wrong you got
to heat it and take take what you get
out of the trade you know so least I got
a little bit of something out of it you
know it was two tix a half a point so it
said it's better than better than taking
taking a loss
or scratch we did come up later you know
930 I sort of fell asleep at the wheel
here and I and I missed this setup part
of the reason was I was talking about
something else at the time I remember
this is the time when I'm in the room
and you know sometimes it's hard to talk
and trade at the same time especially if
I'm looking at another market explaining
something nevertheless there was talk
about this setup you had that you have
the divergence you got a ratio bounce
low so you got a couple things here you
know I add in a couple of sound and
balances there look for that pull back
within two ticks of this high and you
got back within one tick and look for
the sell-off you know you usually this
is a very low-risk trade you and your
stop is going to be just on the other
side of this high at nine and a half it
says going to give you no less than
point of risk you know point max and you
know what's your reward you know you're
getting short here at you know eight and
three-quarters you know we traded down
to six so you know that that's at these
two points you know I'm not saying you
could have held it all the way down here
to four but you know it gave you a very
low-risk trade setup again you know I
fell asleep at the wheel I sort of
looked at it as we're trading in this
bar and realized i missed it you know
for other reasons but nevertheless you
know opportunities do appear throughout
the day then we started going sideways
in here you know got ratio ratio ratio
ratio here you know opposing bearish and
bullish signals usually when the markets
going sideways you'll get that then we
came into our lows here after 10 I
didn't again you have selling snacks
island and balance then you get a buying
signal here with the price trajector and
then you know it's just you know this
sort of cancel each other out so I
didn't take any trade there I took this
trade right off the low I got the price
rejecter right here on the low I got
along in this next bar as a little bit
aggressive i got along at 78 tenth
quarter I didn't really wait for a
pullback even though it traded down to I
think seven and a half you know while I
was in there the next bar we came down
to this point of control here at seven
and a half he got there single print the
six Lots and we got a ratio I had an
offer appear at that nine and
three-quarters
and you know I treated right up there
within 10 minutes boom you know again it
did it go against me yeah I went against
me initially I got in it ain't no
quarter traded down to seven and a half
second quarter i think i think traded
there but it was it was seven and a
quarter seven a half offer before
turning around and popping back up and
you know giving me a chance you know for
a point and a half so you know did this
one it was the winner you know the first
trade that I took was you know a loser
for a point and a half I got a point and
a half back here I got that extra you
know half a points you know earlier on
on this trade that didn't really go go
to my profit targets directly to sort of
spun around and I and I covered it there
for a half a point then there's one
other trade I took in the bonds today
around the same time as that last as a
key trade let me get the bond chart here
okay so bonds had been sort of trading
in a range most of the most of the
morning not 730 we made that low we got
a divergence got a ratio in the market
made a nice move up you know that was a
nice a nice setup but then you know you
just kind of went sideways most of the
morning after 11 we hit this high we got
a ratio up here we got the price
rejecter kicking off there's no
divergence you still got that positive
Delta you know okay it's not the end of
the world I got short here at 28 I'm
sorry 23 168 23 there's quite a bit of
size here at 23 I remember kept
refreshing those iceberg order there so
I was really looking for that move to
get get through there and put a push
lower we traded down to 17 before turn
around i had a bid in at 19 so as a 4
tick for tick trade you know you know
I'm short of 23 if it got up to 26 you
know which is this point of control you
know I would have been a bit more
concerned that the trade wasn't going to
work out but at the same time you know
there was that did there that kept
refreshing as an iceberg order and you
know I really had a strong could we get
through that you know you're gonna see
like a vacuum you see the market get
called lower and it did it happened you
know once we you know we traded over a
thousand before it just fell over
and you got the sound and balances here
here here when we traded down to 19 you
know I filled me that was quick for
ticks unless it quick took about 15
minutes 10 or 15 minutes to happen but
you know what it was was he had too high
you have the ratio on the high you got
the price rejecter given you a cell I'm
saying those there's couple things at
work there and so you know it was at the
end of the day you know I started the
day off with a losing trade you know I
don't like to do that but you know you
can only do what the you know the market
is going to give you know sometimes it's
unfortunate you start out on the back
foot you know and it does affect your
men your mental thinking you know but
you still got to take the trades when
you see them appeared you know I sort of
fell asleep at that wheel on that that
other trade in the e minis but you know
I came back you know I recognized I I
said I ever get my head in that game and
you know when when the next trade
speared you know I cook him you know so
after these two trades and that's it I
was I was done for the day you know and
you know I see the markets in the ESPYs
just sort of fell over late in the day
honestly I didn't really look too much
at that you know that the flow down here
bit curious to see if there's anything
yeah yeah this next price rejecter here
kind of worked up you know this one you
know I'm more inclined to take a price
rejecter signal and it's still after a
move rather than this one were just sort
of you know touched at high three times
yeah if I got it you know couple price
rejecters at the same time I'd probably
thinking it but still not just you know
they've ended in the pier they're just
kind of going sideways now this one is a
better one because you know you have a
move up you know it's a clearer hi this
one is sort of in the middle of this
range and this one you know it got a
nice move down from 81 and a half down
to the 79th another buy signal here
popped up before turn it around you know
anything else couple lows here that the
divergences but nobody shows nothing it
just is just divergence can't just buy
every divergence you see
here you seen a lot of negative ratios
ratio bounds lows indicating prices
being rejected you know above the 79
area and then again you get this it come
down in here at 72 and what do you see
you see 1157 you got a divergence you've
got a racial balance low indicating that
there's some stopping volume and did
hold you know for the short term before
turning around and then coming off going
into the cash close you know then Josh
closed you know the asian session open
and we just sort of well now I don't
call this the agent sections where the
evening session is the priagent session
Asia's you know five in the morning
that's its asian session has it really
opened yet you know then we came up
during the you know during these in
cheshire and hit that high where you
have the divergence you got our ratio
you got the price rejecter see this one
you got its really three things right
here and you know it's just then it's
just sort of went sideways on you you
know when you get you know a good cell
signal the market ends up going sideways
on you it's it's usually a scientific
and get out not necessary to hold its
you know it but you know especially you
know this is just before eight o'clock
and you just going sideways for the next
hour that's really good sign to get out
you know till 20 you know 22 it's
already you know ten o'clock you know
this is just before eight o'clock yeah I
wouldn't hold the position that long if
the trades are not working out you know
rather quickly just just get out so
thanks for watching this video to learn
more about the trading software that I
use in this presentation which you know
I created know a lot of these things are
explained in the software and the
documentation you buy the software you
get a trading course 15 hours of
training and you get access to the
training room to see it in real time you
know visit my website order flows calm
to learn more about my software about me
you know my background in trading and
you know and you know if it's something
that you thinking can help your trading
than neon shoot me an email or purchase
the software so thanks everyone and i'll
catch you on the inside bye bye